first civilization that we have evidence
of around modern-day India and Pakistan
is the Indus Valley Civilisation and
it's right around the Indus River in
modern-day Pakistan and Northwest India
and in other videos we talked about how
it really comes into being in the third
millennium BCE and as we enter into the
second millennium BCE it starts to
decline and we don't know exactly why it
declined might have been climate change
drying up of a river might have been a
natural disaster it might have been an
influence of other people's and we're
going to talk about in this video is the
next significant period in the history
of South Asia and it involves the
migration or the introduction of another
group of people we believe another group
of people and that's the indo-aryans let
me write this down
indo-aryans sometimes referred to as
just the Aryans who we believe start
began to migrate into Northwest into
modern-day Pakistan and Northwest India
at right about the same time that the
Indus Valley Civilisation was declining
and some historians actually believe
well maybe in the Saudi civilization
declined because of them maybe it was
some type of an invasion although that
theory is not as widely held anymore
some folks believe that the indus valley
civilization and this indo-aryan
migration somehow merged but this period
that we're talking about with the
migration of these indo-aryans this is
called the vedic period or the vedic
period and it's called the vedic period
because we learn about it from a
collection of literary works that we get
from that time most famously the Vedas
and Veda comes from Sanskrit and
Sanskrit is the language of the Vedas it
Vedas in Sanskrit means knowledge and
they're the foundation of one what we
know about the Vedic period but they're
also the foundation of modern Indian
culture and religion now the primary the
primary
a pieces of the Vedas are the Rigveda
the yeah or vada the sama Veda and the
Attar vedera and the Rig Veda in
particular is considered the oldest of
the Vedas it's believed that it was
composed around the early part of that
Vedic period between maybe 1500 BCE and
around 1200 BCE so we're talking over
we're talking between 3,000 and 3,500
years ago while these three Vedas we
believe were composed later
now these indo-aryans it's believed were
essentially pastoralists there were
cattle herders perhaps nomadic but as
they began to settle not just the Indus
River Valley they actually began to
settle the entire Gangetic plain which
would include this area which would be
north-east india as well as countries
like Bangladesh in the Indus and the
Ganges or two of the most significant
rivers in India but as they started to
settle the Gangetic plain they also
became more traditional farmers and so
in this green here I've highlighted when
they became more farmers and started to
have more settled kingdoms where we
believe started to have more settle
kingdoms and other significant Hindu
epics we believe the events of them were
happened around that late Vedic period
the events of the Mahabharata and the
Ramayana
now the Vedas and these epic poems were
originally orally transmitted but then
later either in the late Vedic period or
after the Vedic period was when they
were actually written down and just so
you have some context here Sanskrit is
considered one of the oldest
indo-european languages we have and I'll
talk more about indo-european languages
in a little bit because it turns out
that Sanskrit is related to European
languages like Greek and Latin and even
Germanic languages and Sanskrit is one
of the oldest alongside Mycenaean Greek
and the Hittite language and those were
all contemporary civilizations of around
this period right over here in the
second millennium BCE and if you have
context
siddhartha gautama buddha his life was
in one of these Vedic kingdoms in the
North East of India now as I mentioned
the Vedas laid the foundation for much
of what we consider to be modern day
India in fact the first reference
documented reference to the Indus River
we have from the Vedas the Indus Valley
Civilisation we haven't been able to
decipher their writing they didn't write
down the word Indus it was in the Vedas
that we have the word Sindhu and Sindhu
was later changed or mispronounced or or
just trans or pronounced differently
into other words that we now associate
with India words like Hindu Indus and
India they all derived from Sindhu which
was referred to which was the river
referred to in the Vedas and then
changed into Hindu Indus and things like
India now also in the Vedas is the first
time that we have reference to a
stratified social structure and we see
that with the varnas that are referred
to with at the top you have the brunt
and you could use these as the social
roles or classes at the type of the
Brahmins the priests the scholars and
the teachers then the next you have the
Kings and the war is referred to as the
Tkachuk shut Padilla's then the vices or
the farmers emergency artisans and then
the should rise the laborers now some
historians and and Vedic scholars
believe that these reference to the
varnas related were added after the
Vedic period to things like the Rig Veda
and some believed that these weren't
traditional caste as it sometimes
perceived today but just a reference to
different social strata that it wasn't
necessarily inherited we are not
actually sure about that but just to
give you a feel of what was in the Rig
Veda and I encourage you to go look at
the actual primary texts and there's a
lot of there to read it includes prayers
it includes praise of the gods it
includes rituals but also has a lot of
interesting philosophy and for example
this is part of this is from the Rig
Veda this is a hymn referred to as
Mesabi Asuka and
the it's in you could use is a tenth
book the 129th him and I find it really
interesting because it shows a fairly
mature philosophical attitude this is
actually a the origin him and this is
just part of it we're talking about the
origin of the universe who really knows
who will be who will here proclaim it
whence was it produced whence is this
creation God's came afterward with the
creation of this universe who then knows
whence it has arisen whether God's will
created it or whether he was mute
perhaps it formed itself or perhaps it
did not only he who is the overseer and
highest heaven knows only he knows or
perhaps he does not know I just find it
interesting because it takes almost a
little very philosophical view towards
this very fundamental question of the
origin of the actual universe so the
vedic period very important period in
india it really lays the foundation for
what we consider to be modern Hinduism
modern-day India it starts as really a
Bronze Age civilization but as we get
into the later Vedic period we see them
smelting iron and creating iron tools
and and things like that and it's and as
we'll see in the next video the language
of the Vedas the Sanskrit when Western
scholars start to discover it they start
to have it opened up their minds as to
what were the roots of many of the
people who settle not just North India
but also Europe